No too quiet
welcome back to the gingely podcast this
time featuring wine where's my wine
I mean it's Monday for them but it's
Saturday night for us though I'm living
my life in decline
I got no makeup on my leisure suit my
dogs I'm having a great time
hi everyone I should have done it before
we hit record well you can run down
there everyone know you have to stall
it's okay this episode is brought to you
by classpass is an all-access membership
to over 15,000 of the best gyms and
fitness studios all over the world so
you never get bored with your workout
right now go to class pass that CLA SS
PA SS comm / try / Angelina get your
first two weeks for free I'm going to
get home from your awesome workout and
you need to order some food to refill
yourself get on post mates the best
delivery app that there is 24 hours a
day 365 days a year
post mates is the app that delivers
where you previously could not get
delivery we are giving you $100 of free
delivery credits through post post
minutes with our code Jenna Julian
that's je n na ju li en your first 7
days check it out thank you sponsors
thank you sponsors you can go get some
wine I would get a cider really yeah
well will you talk about while I'm gone
just what happened less than an hour ago
outside yeah okay alright time me okay I
used to use the kids anytime me and then
I come back in the woman timing set one
two three okay so anyways I was sitting
outside because like I said it's
Saturday night for us it's Monday for
you or maybe some other day in the
future when you're pushing this that has
nothing to do with any of that anyways
so I was sitting outside we have this
like table that has
gasps propane tank in it and you can
light little like a little fire on it
and it's super nice and I was just
sitting out there enjoying the evening
it was nice and cool oh and all of a
sudden
well marbles was sitting in my shirt I
was wearing this outfit so as you can
see it's like a dog magnet they all want
to sit like in the fleecy comfy lots of
fabric miss they can't wait to sit on my
lap which is also kind of annoying but I
was thinking marbles and I heard like
something walking past me to the right
and it was like the size of Kermit and I
thought it was Kermit and I turn around
it was just a raccoon and he looked at
me I for the record have seen many
raccoons because my dad used to catch
them in our backyard now get really
upset because I thought that they were
just the cutest animal in the world I
would he catch them because they're like
you know you can't have a nest of
raccoons in your garage and have that
just like you're like okay SiC I mean
maybe some people do but it starts to
become a problem okay so my dad would
try and catch them and they would
humanely relocate them to like big parks
and stuff okay but I look at he turn
around I see the raccoon and it was like
a little startled because I thought it
was Kermit and then you turn in to see a
raccoon looking at you like yes [ __ ]
and it was dark out so that's you know
he's it's his time he's living his life
doing his thing and I just went oh he oh
no you can't be here you just looked at
me and then turn around and was like
yeah you bright and then ran away
I was trying I was looking on the camera
see if I had it but he didn't quite
enter the frame really of that camera in
honey but he just walked right up to my
chair like he [ __ ] owned the place
and looked at me and I was like oh oh no
you can't be here I surprised I guess
I'm thinking to the frame now cuz
wouldn't come and fell in the pool that
like cuts off the table yeah but marbles
didn't even notice cuz he was in my
sweater and they keys were inside
because it's just you know slightly
below completely comfortable temperature
out so they couldn't be out there
there are very very much babies when it
gets even remotely cold it to be fair it
is kind of cold out well Kermit came and
sat in my shirt for a little bit but
even that was a little too cold for him
so he went inside really it's too cold
inside the shirt too cold in the shirt
yet or he just didn't like you didn't
like you something about it wasn't to
his liking maybe sitting in there right
now so he owns you
yeah I don't get him sometimes doesn't
matter he does what he wants it's true
yes well this week well you're gonna
take a trip down memory lane of my
childhood this time Andy a couple weeks
ago we went through Jenna's old writing
to her mom and schoolwork schoolwork you
did some poems and this week we're doing
it for me so right here I have this box
don't scare Bobby don't scare him marble
and in this box
uh have you looked at what's in there
because I don't I haven't seen any of
this except for one picture and you're
like high school varsity jacket yeah so
that was actually a little league
all-star jacket oh sorry excuse me
Little League all-stars jacket we didn't
we didn't get varsity jackets in high
school it's weird I feel like we should
have yeah I don't recall us having them
either and I also remember it being sort
of like the beginning of the end of
people wanting to get a high school ring
I have this this is for Allah I think oh
here you could buy it and it was mad
expensive yeah exactly they're all way
too expense yeah so we got the letter
though okay yeah I think they give you
this and then if you want to buy the
jacket right it's like what like a
hundred and fifty dollars yeah so -
insane so in this box [ __ ] 15 and got
the kind of cash
I have some can't do any more car washes
either I have some jerseys that I wanted
to show you so this is my high school
baseball jersey has my name on it
think of what year this was I'm pretty
sure this is my senior year Jews number
five five oh yeah I think it was my
senior year Jersey we didn't have our
names on our jerseys in Tulsa here so
that was pretty cool
and these are my flag football jerseys
from middle school these are kind of
special to me that is really cool it's
from Franklin right here and then this
is the all-star team that made it never
played Santa Monica why did you make it
in then never play I don't know I mean
someone had to ride the bench oh it was
you
it was actually a good time it was a
good time being on that team even though
I didn't play yeah it doesn't matter
so those are my jerseys little picture
of young Julian that's the one that I
was trolling stream with so game ball
did I show you this yeah I did see that
I have a game ball from Little League
any time we got the game ball they would
write what happened and the score and
then your name forgetting the game came
ball Julian was winning pitcher singled
and scored in extra innings Sox won in
the ninth inning wait so you were the
pitcher yeah in this game yeah I was the
pitcher is literally I mean you should
rotate who goes on the mound we won by
one beat the Dodgers 330 104 that's
funny
and then some some leaks are like the
coaches pitch and then some leagues are
t-ball and some leagues showing I know
this I know they actually detect the
technicalities because I was an umpire
in Little League so I know like heavy
and hot everyone get off me I don't feel
bad like you created this situation for
yourself like it's not like it just
happened to you you did that like
digging in that bed so much it's like
shedding okay so when was that
oh yeah I was correcting you cuz I'm a
former Little League UMP and I know more
than you so there's t-ball uh-huh then
there is something called five pitch
mm-hmm where either the coach pitches or
they feed the machine
then there's miners then there's majors
and that's all Italy and the minors and
majors is like everyone plays every
position I mean I said all of that
pretty much except for five pitch got no
[ __ ] violence is where I made most of
my money when I was younger betting on
it Julian I started a betting ring
around the cleaned up the same kids we
just owned every week wasn't even close
oh my god Julian you can't bet on
children's sports do what you want you
don't get caught okay so here we no no
no no flipping you have it if you read
that no then you can't just like flip it
open you have to read it and write and
show it give me a break I was learning
Julian give me a break wait but like no
no no that's like you can write though
you just you spelled your own name wrong
okay you know just let me get to it it's
called the Daily News bye Julian spelled
with an A 98
yeah 98 I was six give me a break
[ __ ] horse I spelled my name wrong I
think this is no 98 okay what's that
this is the legend of how they grade a
check plus or sorry a plus a circled
plus is perfect a plus is no more than
one or two errors in punctuation and
spelling excellent handwriting check
plus three to five errors
check is five or more errors check - is
five or more errors and handwriting is
acceptable
- so Plus is the best you already got a
plus on this page November second I know
I got I got a plus in a circle I did
really well perfect
November 2nd 98 we made our November
calendars and we did what what what is
Indio Indian photographs okay
pictographs that says o pictographs
you're right I couldn't even read that
okay because my handwriting was too
small see I was supposed to
basically I got corrected with the size
of my handwriting it should have been
because it has those like hash lines so
that your letters are supposed to go up
to that half mark mm-hmm fun oh and then
I just redid the same since November
third we have we have a new kind of
daily news books
we played tunnel tag at PE hotel oh
thanks fun what's tunnel tag I forget
that you said it was fun it is fun
calling your bluff what is it you know I
don't okay okay I'll hear it okay so
some people are on their hands and knees
and then it's like tag you're it but you
have to run under your friends basically
you make a tunnel with your hand oh no
you stand with your legs spread open so
that B creates the tunnel yeah but it's
the same concept yeah like you have to
go through people and then tag okay this
is really basic like I was stupid we
made cornbread at cooking we played a
game with bean backs a lot better though
your handwriting is really good yeah
this I think this is a camera no first
grade your six six really high first
grade oh let's see what what my teacher
was it doesn't say anywhere I used to
love drawing aliens this is like my
favorite thing to draw like aliens just
like the green face we read our
Halloween stories and our Indian stories
to our big buddies we did cool
experiments with magnets
that's so cute Julie oh I have my grade
report oh no I saved so many this middle
school Lincoln Middle School
see I like Julianne yellow from a young
age
oh my god I got to show you something
this is the worst thing ever my eye when
my mom pulled this out of she is like
boxes and boxes of old [ __ ] like this of
ours when we were young and I went to
her house and I got this stuff and we
were going through the different boxes
and she pulled this one out and just
started dying laughing at it and said
I'm keeping this one this one's too good
and I've made her give it to me
this is drawing I drew of my elementary
school girlfriend and me kissing and I
drew her taller than enough she's taller
than me why did I draw her taller than
me she's owning me she's just dominating
me if you get listening if you're
listening the drawing of the back of and
I'm wearing not easy I made sure to show
what makes Brando's ring Wow always
about that brand yeah love those brands
weird why was I doing there let's see
what go Pat's from an early age okay
what is this here okay this is a letter
to my dad I haven't read this so I'm
just gonna go for it
hopefully this is good dear dad this is
only one of the 365 days that I love you
I want to let you know that you are the
greatest dad in the whole world
and I want to thank you for taking me to
all the baseball games that I've been to
playing catch with me - yes stupid I
hate Christmas playing catch with me
playing hockey with me coming to all my
games being there for me this is a
ronson supporting our family working
everyday to pay for everything punishing
me when I deserved it wanting me to what
does that say wanting me to something
out night out right turn out right
making me happy being my hero
taught me how to live my life I love you
so much thank you for there's like 12
exclamation point yeah that's a lot of
exclamation thank you for being so funny
and making everybody laugh and happy
thank you for loving me the way you do
happy Father's Day
this was must have been like passing for
it was a nice letter I wrote I haven't
read any of this stuff so I don't like I
don't know Hugh do you wanna see first
of all you got an a a - a - with a plus
under it dude a - is my city okay Julien
sulamita 314 93 so you were what 314 93
mm-hmm no it doesn't say 9303 yeah I was
11 okay this is my fondest I don't think
I knew cursive at 1 okay um one day I
was walking down the street and I
suddenly heard a sound as if a coin had
fallen on the pavement this is a really
legible Kherson really good cursive I
slowly picked it up like I like how if
you you have a word that you can't fit
all the way in you just start the next
letters over next Lane I slowly picked
it up and had a picture of some sort of
leprechaun later that day I took it home
and put it under a 500 time magnifying
glass surprisingly it read you shall be
granted three wishes it took me a minute
to get the message then I realized what
had happened I picked up the coin
squeeze it and said I wish for world
peace the reason I would wish for world
peace is so America as well as every
other country won't interact with each
other
another wreath okay another reason I
would wish for that is so that no one
will get hurt
he's so sweet my next wish was for me to
have xbox live exercises for Xbox what
it does is it allows you to compete
against other people in different
locations I want it because if I got it
I wouldn't have to go to my friend's
house Julie that's so pure I couldn't
think of my last wish until later when
it hit me it was to have an underage
driver's license and a Corvette the next
morning after I woke up and all my
wishes came true the end boy you have
world peace Xbox Live and an underage
guy I was pretty good list Wow but like
you're an inherently good person Julian
which is why your first wish was world
peace and not Xbox Live because then I
wouldn't seem kind of me well yeah I
couldn't come off like that I had all
right be careful with this stuff you
know look at this picture of my dad and
my mom and me oh my god it's [ __ ]
great oh it's great okay you're watch
god you're so cute I'm such a [ __ ] damn
yo you parents and fresh as hell in this
picture though lugia mom's pants oh yes
she has him styled she's always had
always been out here class of 2003 on
did you graduate how that must've been
my elementary graduation oh this is
literature notebook I want to find my
life I feel like you're missing out on
all this gold I know I just really want
to find my summer journal how I see
myself okay this is like a really
intense book report I think I didn't
middle school I don't know this sounds
great my Spring Break by Julian sulamita
my Spring Break all started out when I
had a sleepover my friend Adam's house
in the morning my mom picked me up I am
your mom Playboy okay this is my vision
board playboy things that I liked okay
oh god sorry I didn't mean to cut you
off all right you ready yeah you first
of all your mom picked you up from a
sleepover at 8 a.m. after that we
stopped to pick up our friends and then
we went to the airport we going to New
York oh that's way we flew JetBlue
airlines on JetBlue airlines each person
gets their own TV screen remote and
headset so you're able to watch anything
you want whenever you want
we arrived in New York about 5:00 p.m.
the first thing we did there was rent a
car at National Car Rental which took
about three hours to do because there
was a really long way so after that we
drove to our friend's cousin's house to
stay at the next day we drove from
Queens to Manhattan that w went to
Central Park we also we also went to
places like FAO Schwartz Ray's Pizza
Times Square and Ground Zero at Times
Square whoa you went to Ground Zero
that's crazy
FAO Schwartz that's so wild to like see
you write that I was like in I was a
sophomore in high school and that
happened mm-hmm at Times Square we
visited Toys R Us Quicksilver and ESPN
Zone you went to the Empire State
Building this is cute
you went to New York is this the trip
where you and your brother were in that
hotel room and you made that video where
he Marlon keeps like being like look at
the building you'd be like dude - dude
stop stop get out get out
you're like anyways here's my trip to
New York I should upload that video it's
really gonna happen somewhere we were
staying in this hotel and we went out on
to the fire escape and I was literally
carrying my MacBook to film the video
yeah and we were just looking at the
emergency I carried my MacBook to film
picking up marbles because that was the
only camera that I had all right sorry
but you're good I really liked that
vision board
this is just this is literature notebook
so I'm Oh Sarah Palin no Sarah Plain and
Tall dammit who's the real Sarah it's
about a book and then I go through like
sick s my guy you know I had to do it to
him with the Stu CS yeah this is mostly
just like about books so it doesn't
really make sense there's no context
family journal let's see what this well
this is good February 22nd mm my grandma
came to visit our family how will do you
in 2008 she's absolutely a good cook oh
I'm moving to a new house it has
absolutely Howard amongest backyard oh
my god I could play a real game of foot
- ball how mungus I could invite a lot
one word of friends and give out jerseys
versus I give out different jerseys my
team will be the 49ers and it would be
grown-ups versus kids the grown-ups Gron
ups will be the Denver Broncos and we
would have a total blast total blast
this this is what we've been looking for
oh this is so cute oh my god February
29th I went to my friend's birthday
party today it was yeah it's true it was
at Ultra Zone which is in the valley
that's so fun it's a laser tag place me
and my friends had a blast it was
Michael's birthday party it is a laser
tag place good job not daxing Michael
yeah I'm not gonna Doc's any thank you
did some my my boy Aaron that's that we
did this yeah but I bleeped it off we
played video games too I just got a
thank-you letter from him I'm moving to
a different house I already mentioned
that is the best house I've ever seen in
my whole life
it is home I guess
oh just keep saying is huge it also has
a huge back house in the huge backyard
it is a big house some my teacher wrote
I'm impressed with how much you tell
with your writing she spelled my name
right though
but way at the end if you get a bad
grade you're like yeah
Julianne wrote that I'm Julianne for a
new subject in the next story I'm moving
to a new house it is so cool it is my
second house it has a playroom it has a
fake kitchen it is so awesome I love it
I think I'm not sure that it is my
second house but I think my birthday is
coming up I'm gonna have a lot of super
fun I'm gonna have a football game I'm
gonna go to Ultra zone it is the best
like this is crazy you're just like
you're really excited to move yeah and
like play sports with your friends yeah
that's about it
you're so sweet that's so wild okay keep
going no I'm invested now March 14 you
know we had a change of plans
we're moving on Tuesday I just slept
over in my new house it's awesome we
thought we were moving on Wednesday our
house is the best house I ever moved to
our old house looks empty I love it so
much
my grandma is here GA re - she slept at
our new house I might have a play date
with Jason
we could play Gameboy with each other
the end see I was hanging out with Jason
way back then
Matthew is at my house right now we are
playing handball with Matthew we have
that you're playing involved
I walk home by myself because my new
house is much more close to school than
my old house oh I have a play date with
Matthew every week at a certain day that
is Monday mmm
why did I have to say a certain day I'm
playing at my new house I might go to
Mountain High where's Martin hi what's
that it's a ski resort like an hour
outside it's not those like a high
school no mountain no it sounds like
Mountain High is like the quickest way
to ski from like LA but it's not that
great big red better all right I don't
ski so well I mean just like as a town
like a ski telling a little mountain
town Resort thing whatever I have a new
Pokemon collector's item book oh it is
really really special
very spent very special well introduced
for one second spell that how about that
special he's really really SPE a CS ail
and then the second time I spelled SPE
CI s EA I oh my god my brother has one
too
I have a lot of cool tattoos but they
press-ons oh they have awesome Pokemon
on them oh I was getting like Pokemon
tattoos yeah I'm getting used to this
house my mom might paint some of the
inside of this new house I'm on a new
baseball team I'm on the Orioles oh I
remember the Orioles
that's a damn April 4th mm it's almost
your birthday I had a really fun over
the over the weekend I had really fun
over the weekend first of all I had fun
because I went to a game it was a
basketball game I saw my basketball
coach at the basketball game and I saw
another friend at the basketball game it
was Michael from last year Jason took me
to the game it was at this table Center
it was my first basketball game it was
the Lakers versus the 76ers yeah my
birthday is on April 17th I can't wait
till
my birthday party comes and I don't
believe that my birthday party is the
same as your birthday party what I'm
going to have a blast first of all I'm
going to go bowling and when you go
bowling for a party you get free bowling
and you get a free bowling pin
I remember that it wasn't free somebody
paid for that thing
and guess what every day you're part
your party sign it everybody at your
party sign it mm-hmm I remember that boy
yeah I thought that was so cool it's
really cool wait so we skipped over your
birthday now it's May 2nd yeah I got too
excited to journal oh my god will you
not you will not believe what I did for
spring break
b ra ke first of all I went to San
Francisco to my Grandma and Grandpa's
house and I went to a lake it was really
really much fun we can't do that Lake
the lake was called Buena Vista I think
I actually spelt that perfectly we went
to a cool arcade and we bought a big
mowed motorboat mo de are May 9th
it's Marlins birthday party today that's
it first of all his birthday is the 7th
so the date is wrong and I only wrote
that Saturday these are my favorite you
know what's my favorite is not getting
caught up in one type of workout Julian
I swear to God class pass do you don't
have to get caught up in one type of
workout you can I'm gonna look for my
phone but until then I'm just gonna add
lib you can sign up for class pass and
they give you options to all sorts of
different types of workouts and gyms you
can do kickboxing you could do yoga you
could do Pilates you could do
weightlifting you could do CrossFit
there's all sorts of options so that you
can never get bored with your workout
routine and right now right like right
this moment you get your first two weeks
for
free at clasp ask.com slash try slash
ever Julian that means if you click the
link in the description right and you
sign up with our URL you get two weeks
to test it out for free so you can mix
it up try the different workouts to do
see what's around you
maybe you've driven by a lot of workout
places and you thought to yourself man
that would be fun to work out there and
you're like I don't want to go in there
and sign up well class pass does that
for you it's your all-in-one pass it
makes it super convenient to vary up
your training and so you can have fun
with fitness and you don't feel like
you're getting bored with a stale
workout routine you can try new things
and it's also a cool thing to do with
friends so wouldn't it be great to try
something new without the financial
commitment of one single gym or the
commitment they make often times or yes
okay every month no actually you don't
know if you're gonna like it it exactly
with class pass if you don't like one
you have so many others to choose from
that's over fifteen thousand of the best
gyms and fitness studios all over the
world to choose from also a really good
reason to do this is if you travel you
have class pass wherever you go which is
really cool so right now I can finally
go to hip toss sumbitches you go dude I
[Music]
already know careful with is the best
sport ever it's just not for me that's
all well that's fine it is still the
best word ever class pass calm slash try
slash Jenna Julianne Thank You class
pass also guys post mates are you hungry
are you craving Taco Bell Carl's jr.
always french fries just sushi I mean
whatever you want in your life you don't
have to go get it's like the worst
motivational speech ever don't go get
whatever you want
most mates to go get it for you okay
like calm down just you know put your
feet up take your shoes off before you
put your feet up then put your feet up
cuddle with your dog or your cat unless
your cat doesn't like to be cuddled I
feel like a lot of cats don't really
like cuddling they're kind of just
independent creatures but once your
feeder is up and you have your animal
where you want it think about what you
want to eat and then go on the postmates
app and get it it is truly an amazing
app that we use literally all the time
every single week we use this thing
whether we're ordering a meal because we
know time to cook or we're ordering
things from the grocery store so we
don't have to actually go to the grocery
store and
convenient and right now you can get
$100 of free delivery credits on your
postman's account when you use code
Jenna Julian that's je n na ju li e n
and get post matin ok 24 hours a day
there are things on the post mates menu
that you can get so check it out you
will not be disappointed
Thank You sponsors may 23rd mm I went on
the best trip ever it was with all my
friends it was at Yosemite you you will
not believe what happened I was click
baiting you will not believe what
happened in Yosemite I heard a bear it
was a family reunion I remember that
experience of hearing the bear it was
terrifying it was when we were packing
up to leave like 4:00 a.m. yeah and it
was very loud forget that we heard a
bear too quite a sound yes we did a bear
growl at us yes we did Big Bear
that was [ __ ] gnarly yeah well I mean
when we would go camping like when I was
younger and the Adirondacks and stuff
like you see bears and you hear bears
and they'll go through your stuff but
they're like little they're just not
like life-threatening like they are out
west you have like grizzly bears and
bears a little [ __ ] your [ __ ] up yeah
but like where I grew up they're like
little black bears little brown bears
that are like teehee I want your
marshmallows oh my god I don't like
noises then they run away you know those
are the kind of bands that are out here
they're not you know polar or grizzly
bears out here they're just chilling nah
Yosemite oh well Yosemite is not here
though that's northern California that's
like scary [ __ ] well I mean I still
don't even actually know what kind of
bears are out there it could be black
and brown bears well I'm sure there's
lots of different kinds of bears but
there's they're [ __ ] out there
nonetheless though the Bears where I
grew up where like the the bear in that
vine that's like jumping across the
river yeah polar bears are probably the
scariest type about that they're Israel
oh yeah those gnarly
May 30th I went to get a new something
at Blockbuster it was the new Star Wars
Episode one I saw it in the movies and
saw about it a thousand i saw it about a
thousand times it is one of the best
super best best movies I've seen in my
whole life okay
take take it take it as love Star Wars
Episode one I don't
oh and one more thing it's not that new
to do it June 6 can't be that new if you
rented it from block but yeah it's
always a little while that's so cool
I remember seeing that movie we saw the
same movie anyway you've all seen Star
Wars
oh good how have we never talked about
this I don't know you saw Star Wars
before yeah me too what
yesterday I had a baseball game it was
so so so much fun I play the shortstop
position I used to play second base but
then my coach put me at shortstop and so
my coach thought I was a good shortstop
oh and I won my championship game now
I'm going to move over to the minor
leagues that's so exciting
oh I thought I was oh that must have
been Oh your mom world at the top that
was a great game I love to watch you
play love mom oh my god that is my mom
so funny
around this alright that's it this
journal oh I love that Journal ten out
of ten
that was my favorite book so far ever
that I've ever read in my whole life I
want to see your student grade report
these are my yearbooks I kind of want to
just see what's written on them like
what's this we were talking about this
earlier I haven't seen any of these but
like I was always the kid that was like
I needed to write really neatly and I
would always open my
your book to someone to let you have
them write it in the spot that I think
would look good you know yeah okay so
this what you're looking at here is this
is just really shitty work by Julian
okay we were supposed to keep summer
journals and sometimes we would go on
like little road trips and I would
forget it and also this is what you get
just two random pieces of paper so
August 2nd and August 3rd with no year
no year but I can kind of estimate I
think it's probably my go to or a three
do I'm gonna read this okay today I woke
up my mom said I used to start every
single journal entry that way today I
woke up yeah and she would always tell
us like I know you don't have to say
that today I woke up and went down went
downtown with a bunch of people I wrote
them all out but I'll just skip that I
couldn't believe how many stores there
were it was so unbelievable there were
streets and stores all over we walked
around a lot until we got to this one
gene store and stayed there for a while
then we went on I thought of in as a big
promenade oh I thought of it as a big
promenade after walking and walking for
about one hour and a half we got
sunglasses for everybody so I'm talking
about downtown LA where you there's like
the alleys and you can like shop at
those little yeah everyone got something
and we got presents for all of our
cousin cousins everyone was really happy
about everything we all thanked everyone
and I ate a hot dog then everyone ate
eight to eight I don't know what that
says
I got an Ichiro shirt then the Red Sox
won six to three to the Yankees six to
three in the Yankees won nine to four
Chicago won and we were all happy why am
i reporting all the baseball scores then
we went to dinner and then I went to
sleep fun what a fun day fun day I
actually want to look at this really
quick so this is let's say Lincoln
Middle School I want to see you put
he's found purple he's for don't he's
sleeping like a little angel you leave
beat damn whose signature is that that's
[ __ ] still cool oh that one yeah yeah
I had some friends who were good it
looks like graffiti wait it's all over
the front it's the same thing over and
over again what is that oh maybe that
was me no I don't think it was me I
don't know okay I are Yuri did you read
it is that why you're laughing yeah
here's to a good this is my yearbook so
we would sign your are your books so
this is someone someone else sent us
here's to a good summer I hope to see
you we should hang keep in touch from
your Jewish Jewish friend Danny stay
Jewish is so sweet and pure it's funny
and funny as hell that is funny Jewish
friend Danny staged a Jewish state
George read some they're cute really
yeah you don't even have to say their
names you know this is a good one hey
Julien it was quote unquote fun sitting
next to you at math you kind of annoyed
me but not a lot he you're actually a
great person hackus Brenda have a
kick-ass summer oh yeah Julian you're so
tight and a baller
Malcolm why oh you are you're so tight
and a baller
this is wild dude Wow Wow well I want to
read some yeah okay one side one side
let's stay cool over the summer see you
next year round okay that person wrote
hi my name is and then cross out the
word [ __ ] you will remember this
forever that is a Power Move I
got that has a lot of profanity in it
but then it's like crossed out it says
yeah that's inappropriate it's very yeah
so people who did that in my yearbook
just don't they weren't my friends but
they got to my yearbook somehow it's
like I remember there was time to like
if you had like a period where everyone
started passing them around and you
would see like who's you were signing or
whatever and you just write something
really generic but if you're a [ __ ] yeah
you'd write something weird like that
dear Julian Hey ugly hope you become
cuter over the summer have a great one
Jerome damn jerome really [ __ ] you are
[ __ ] bodied by drum oh this one is
great this is um what year is this 2004
everyone wrote there am Wow there's no
messages anymore it's just like there is
now it's like this is the progression we
know this is the wow they really are oh
my god that's so sadly and read it
Julian read it that's the saddest thing
please did you okay okay
that is so [ __ ] do you remember that
story I told about how I showed up to
the school dance and my PE clothes yes
this was that school dance yes
Tamela reiden Julian you're a really
great friend and I thank you for all you
have done for me also got friend-zoned
hard off the top ah I don't think I was
the one I got friend-zoned also I had a
fun time at the Valentine's Day dance
even though you left because you had a
stomachache there was I was gonna say
did you ever see a diagnosis before that
I remember that I used pretended to have
a stomachache after you showed up better
than my pee because you're just like the
worst did you know that that poor girl
dress up in a dress and got all sweaty
you showed up in your PE clothes and
then you faked a stomachache she forgive
she for
we're still friends I don't forgive you
I I am holding a lifetime grudge for
that shouts out Haley I'm sorry for
saying unforgivable I do not know you
that well
okay guess summer some of these people I
was gonna say some of these kids are
really good handwriting and these are
all my teachers man Julian you're an
awesome person and I like you a lot
you're a great friend funny too let's
hang out this summer or next year play
some sports or something Zoe hmm don't
worry I do the heart with everyone yeah
you just want to make sure you weren't
getting into acid yeah well you know oh
my god what up dawg thank for this year
kptl keep pimping the ladies Oh God we
only all of that friends it was like way
too into like boyfriends and girlfriends
way too young you know yeah and that was
him dude Julian thanks for the card it
was very cool because you're probably
the only person who remembered my
birthday
thanks a lot anyways you're a really
great friend I'll probably see you next
year have a great summer Malcolm
he called me dope the following year so
we had a good friendship yeah
hot cast Logan you suck at football he's
getting body left and right you suck at
football yeah yeah the hackus or the
hags was like very lazy like you didn't
really really never yeah that's kind of
all we did Wow
I would definitely be the person that
writes hags though because I would never
dare write something that stood for
kick-ass I would get in trouble like
big-time trouble
really yeah I was not allowed to swear
Julian this is from one of my teachers
Julian you did a good job in my class
with more self-discipline you can do
even greater work very best mr. Brown
mr. Brown was wonderful he hated me but
he was like oh wise words you reminded
me of Stanley from the office he's the
exact same person who's Stanley from the
office and he taught me math Tommy math
he just we got away with so much [ __ ] in
that class cuz he was just like he
didn't care and you thought he wasn't
looking because he wasn't reacting yeah
but then at the end of the year he write
something like that no and a muse for
her yeah yeah this is [ __ ] wild wait
so are those like circles what you're
circling people and crossing out people
yeah damn yeah it wasn't like a you know
III would circle my friends and the
people I liked and then the people who
were mean to me I like crossed out so I
don't have to look at him yeah I think
that's where my my head was that I also
wouldn't dare ever write in my yearbook
like that oh yeah my yearbook is marked
up these are my grades alright I want to
see okay alright these are the same one
yeah let's beg what's beg wins that says
BG w are beginning winds beginning winds
what's that like the instrument winds
playing oh wait would you play the
French horn that's not that's not a wind
that was the class it was like winds and
whatever else it was like a class the
brasses yeah that was the name of the
class though this is middle school right
Lincoln since 2004 this is Lincoln oh my
god I have the best poem ever 2004 is
Lincoln Middle School Walter you middle
school age okay 12 to 15 or whatever I
don't know a wins a minus a minus on
French horn no I had to do it
to him again in speech you got an a
English you got a nanny - history got a
b-plus and a B math you got a b-plus B+
science a b-plus physical education
double a's Wow okay good
how's a beast what a very good student
woman I was as you say a big beast can I
read this poem that you're gonna love
yeah there's no date
it's just a ball great Julie and
salomina when I write my name it looks
like a yellow flash of lightning it
sounds like an alien speaking it smells
like a huge fire my name is the rhythm
of a cheetah charging it also looks like
a messy snowboarder yeah that was pretty
accurate what the hell are those
visually frame that maybe yeah just take
a picture of it and then just print it
and we'll cover an entire room with it
you know paper they're gonna picture
really nice and tasteful had to do it to
him here's a novel I wrote called the
chick by Julian that's cute the chick by
Julian there was a chick he went to a
pond so cute you Illustrated all this
oh yeah illustrations all by the author
as well cute he fell in the pond oh no
he came to ashore skipped over a really
important part there he walked
and walked he found his mother he came
to his house that's it then about the
author
there's the cruise know the end it's
just my name is Julian I'm six years old
I have a tool belt I'm going to see
Paulie the movie my class has an
incubator my class has an incubator come
on
I have a tool belt oh yeah I'm taking a
picture of this too this is this is rich
that book is really good yeah this is a
there was a chick was a chick good it's
like a movie trailer
this is an alien writing some sort of
scooter spaceship with a jersey on and
cargo pants I don't know what I was
thinking I like drawing aliens okay
there's that this is my I think
elementary school oh man we know what is
cool is this memories by Julian I used
to play I like to play basketball I'm
good at it Wow humble I like to I was
sorry I go to so sore
soccer socr I'm a really good player our
il le a good soccer player I'm good at
basketball
okay that's a cute picture my favorite
thing on the first day of school was
I can't literally can't read that words
so cute how much later your hair was and
then it got darker as you go when I was
a kid my hair was blond
I know yeah my hair was like fully
blonde my mom called me a towhead and
then I just had hair turned dark so
funny and you read my spring break right
mm-hmm
a dog of my own so cute was that the dog
of my own we shared our connections to
the story I saw it so we're talking
about the literature notebook sort of
I'm out a book I said that my friend has
a dog I'm going to get a gecko two of
them one is for me and one is for my
sister Becky said that she had a friend
that had a nice dog delete said her
neighbor had two dogs okay ribbiting
this is the weirdest tration of a
b-minus [ __ ] okay um yeah I'm not gonna
read a book for us okay but this is a
book report on a book called crackerjack
half back and I remember that I remember
these Matt Christopher books have you
heard of them they were like sports
books and I loved them I feel like that
sounds really familiar like I feel like
I can remember what the paperback looked
like yes there was a ton of them and
they all had different sports and
stories I love this one
this was good yeah UNICEF I just watch a
movie about UNICEF and I learned
something that I didn't even think was
possible kids die of hunger every day
more than 30,000 this year I am
definitely going to collect as much
money as possible and I think you should
too is it remember you'd go
trick-or-treating with the UNICEF thing
did you do that no oh [ __ ] so when we
were in elementary school they get they
would give them at school and it's like
a cardboard little you'd have to like
build it it's a flatcar bow and you
build it out and it turns into like sort
of like a little piggy bank and you go
around it says UNICEF on it and you go
around with your trick-or-treating bag
and
and getting candy you say would you like
to die to UNICEF and then the next day
at school you'd bring it on the change
that you made and donated to UNICEF yeah
that's why I was October see I like this
picture alien how wait so you drew this
on a computer oh yeah yeah it's printed
yeah yeah but that's like Microsoft
Paint or something always the computer
artist pictures of me and my brother
what is going on here this is also a
computer picture he's got a weight
mustache milk mustache maybe I loved
like I love drawing people you've always
been really good at drawing well I have
my mom has heaps of my childhood
drawings like so many she also has tons
of photos but we decided to go through
just some of the schoolwork for this
episode of the podcast because I I knew
that this is the type of stuff that we
wanted it's real I really liked that
journal you did it was really good
there's probably more summer journal
entries somewhere too but I guess that's
kind of the main the main piece of it
newspaper from the day I was born that's
so cool that's really nicely preserved -
yeah it's actually perfectly preserved
still in its original like steel back
yet
75 cents that's so cool
this is really cool yeah this is very
cool oh there you go that's a little a
little piece of mine I was really fun
I'd say some of the highlights for me
were the chick from your Jewish friend
Danny stay Jewish Jewish yeah I really
like that whole Journal that whole thing
it's funny because reading a lot of the
stuff whether it be a book report or a
journal entry or my yearbook like it
brings up vivid memories vivid memories
of people and experiences and like
feelings and [ __ ] it's so weird man
because there was so many years ago like
I was reading we were reading [ __ ] from
1998 mm-hmm that's almost 20 years ago
what the [ __ ] that's crazy I'm
referencing something 20 years ago in my
life that's great life he's crazy dude
um I also would like to say one of the
highlights was you spelling your name
wrong well you had to learn somehow so
dynamite
well hope you guys enjoyed that was fun
I enjoyed thank you for sharing Julianne
yeah and thank your mom for saving all
that and letting you at least borrow it
shouts out to my mom if you're gonna
keep that here that we have to find
someone really safe and good for it yeah
yeah yeah I want to have it wherever I
know I well there's a lot of stuff yeah
there's lots I don't want to keep
preserved and like a box safely but then
there's a lot of stuff in here that I'd
love to actually frame like some of the
pictures I'm down I'm down for that poem
that poem is sick the one of my name yes
it's pretty good poem yes it is yeah
well anyway guys have a good week thank
you for hanging out with us for another
podcast we'll see you next week and
remember
if your parents saved things like this
from your childhood they did a good job
Thank You parents what good also learn
how to spell your name right there was a
check remember there was a chick alright
guys have a good week
[Music]